bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
vous maragoillet bonsoir vous êtes
enseignante en histoire-géographie
depuis 25 ans en collège vous venez de
publier finir prof chez Robert Laffont
une histoire de profs heureux épanoui
vraiment satisfaite de faire votre
métier c'est rare et ça fait du bien on
va en parler tout à l'heure on est
ensemble pendant une heure pour
décrypter l'actualité de ce mercredi 11
janvier et l'actualité ce soir c'est
encore les retraites bien sûr au
lendemain des annonces cette question la
réforme est-elle juste carrière longue
pénibilité certains découvrent
aujourd'hui qu'ils devront cotiser 44
ans alors les plus modestes les plus
fragiles sont-ils les grands perdants
c'est notre grand débat dans un instant
et puis aux alentours de 20h15 les
partis pris de nos affranchis et puis
notre nouveau rendez-vous Bourbon
Express ce soir
de retour controversé celui d'arrêt de
rien catenens à l'Assemblée vous me
suivez maragueille c'est parti sévère
[Musique]
le travail c'est la santé vraiment on va
se poser la question ce soir juste ou
injuste cette réforme des retraites
bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir merci d'être
là vous êtes député renaissance du
Loiret en première ligne sur cette
réforme je crois savoir que vous en
serez la rapporteur dans l'hémicycle
bonsoir Sophie tailler paulian ravi de
vous avoir sur ce plateau député
écologiste du Val-de-Marne très remontée
on l'a vu aux questions au Gouvernement
hier contre cette réforme tout comme
vous Cyril Chabanier bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes le président
de la CFTC les syndicats tous unis dans
la rue le 19 janvier prochain enfin
bonsoir Gérald Kierzek ravi de vous
retrouver médecin urgentiste la médecine
du travail elle est solliciter dans
cette réforme on va en parler pénibilité
on va parler chargée lourdes sANTÉ
CARRIÈRE longue ce soir maragoillet ce
débat intéresse les citoyens mais aussi
les enseignants je suis sûr qu'ils
regardent ça activement très près vous
pouvez intervenir quand vous le
souhaitez mais nous pour nous planter
d'accord comme chaque soir j'appelle mon
camarade Stéphane blackovski juste ou
injuste il a deux secondes pour nous le
dire le chrono de Baco tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à tous à toutes alors juste moi juste
écoutez puisque vous me donnez 200
secondes à l'endroit tu as l'essentiel
on va dire que tous les syndicats sont
d'accord pour dire que cette réforme est
injuste bon on va pas non plus
caricaturer il y a quand même des
nuances de points de vue d'un syndicat
l'autre regardez la CFDT trouve que la
réforme est injuste oui mais aussi
brutale ce qui n'est pas tout à fait le
point de vue de faux dit elle a je
réforme est injuste et
inefficace autre son cloche la réforme
est injuste et
injustifié bon il y a quand même un truc
sur lequel tout le monde est d'accord
chez les syndicats c'est que c'est très
fort et injuste alors je sais pas si
vous pourrez faire preuve d'un peu
d'empathie ce soir pour Isabelle bande
parce que la pauvre elle doit être super
déçue non parce que le pilier de sa
réforme c'était la justice c'est un des
piliers regardez c'est marqué sur le
dossier de presse justice en premier
équilibre progrès et dans son discours
hier il y a des logiciels vous savez
aujourd'hui qui permettent de compter le
nombre de fois on a prononcé un mot et
donc hier dans le discours de 20 minutes
elle a dit 12 fois justice en tête 11
fois progrès et 10 fois et qui tout ça
en 20 minutes donc c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui lui tenait à cœur et
donc le point fort pour la question de
la justice c'est l'idée que ceux qui ont
des carrières longues qui ont commencé à
travailler dès l'adolescence et bien on
prendra soin d'eux comme l'expliquer la
PM c'est à dire que la première ministre
un système juste c'est permettre à ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt de
partir plus tôt
nous allons conserver et améliorer le
dispositif des carrière longue en le
rendant plus juste et plus lisible
alors c'est là que ça coince parce que
en fait elle avait à côté d'elle quand
elle disait ça un petit tableau donc
c'est bien fait d'ailleurs pour résumer
la situation au premier coup d'œil on se
dit bah oui évidemment vous commencez à
travailler à 14 ans vous partez quand
même bien avant les autres six ans avant
les autres à 58 ans pareil on fait un
petit calcul
si vous travaillez à 14 ans et donc 44
ans avant d'atteindre l'âge légal si
vous travaillez à 16 ans 44 ans pour
atteindre l'âge légal pour partir à la
retraite mais c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
avait dit non je suis désolé elle l'a
dit elle-même le principe c'est que au
bout de 43 annuités on peut se casser on
écoute
nous n'irons pas plus loin que les 43
ans de cotisations prévues par la
réforme Touraine pour partir avec une
retraite à taux plein
c'est un peu embarrassant moi je suis un
peu gêné comment expliquer que tout le
monde doit partir à 43 ans à la retraite
sauf ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
à l'adolescence qui devrait voir
attendre 44 ans je ne sais pas qui a
prévu nos défendre ce point de la
réforme je lui souhaite bien du courage
et bon débat merci beaucoup merci pour
ce chrono parfaitement respecté et bien
piquant ce soir elle est pour vous cette
question Stéphanie hérisson on va parler
des carrières longs tout le monde a très
bien compris quand vous avez travaillé
tôt 17 18 on a vu même un peu plus tôt
même si il y a beaucoup moins de
Français qui sont dans ce cas de figure
vous pourrez partir plus tôt ça ça
existe déjà je croyais que le dispositif
carrière longue il allait être amélioré
pour être encore plus juste 44 ans vous
travaillez un peu plus tard vous avez
fait des études ça sera 43 s'il reste
que c'est juste ça franchement oui mais
en fait personne pose la question
question de si on ne fait pas de réforme
qu'est-ce qui se passe pour ces pour ces
jeunes de moins de 20 ans actuellement
ces jeunes de moins de 20 ans
actuellement ils sont dans le cadre de
la réforme Touraine qui devait toucher
sans la réforme qu'on propose les gens
nés avant à partir de 1973 donc c'est
les jeunes de maintenant il pourrait
pour certains de voir avoir à cotisé 44
ou 45 ans donc effectivement pour cette
partie de population c'est 44 ans
vous avez un cas de figure très
concrètement parce que là on rentre dans
le détail forcément vous avez 18 19 ans
aujourd'hui c'est 44 ans la durée de
cotisation pour partir à 62 c'est bien
ça oui c'est ça je peux le loup de la
réforme la justice elle est vraiment sur
le fait que quand vous avez une carrière
longue vous partez avant ceux qui n'ont
pas de carrière longue et je crois qu'il
faut aussi distinguer dans les carrières
longues il y a effectivement le temps de
cotisations mais il y a aussi le fait
que certaines carrières longues ne sont
pas forcément reliées à la pénibilité ça
me semble un point intéressant à
apporter parce que dans l'esprit des
gens quand on fait une carrière longue
c'est forcément pénible
pas forcément il y a des entiers qu'on
peut faire et où avoir une carrière
longue dans sa vie avoir changé de
métier et avoir cotisé avant 20 ans sans
pour autant que ce soit pénible alors je
vais me tourner vers le syndicat
d'espace parce que on met carrière
longue les gens ne connaissent pas
forcément ce dispositif déjà c'est un
dispositif il faut justifier un certain
nombre de trimestres quand on a commencé
jeune c'est ça et on peut bénéficier
d'un départ anticipés pour bien
comprendre on peut bénéficier d'un
départ anticipé à la condition d'avoir
des trimestres cotisés avant ses 20 ans
et d'ailleurs dans la nouvelle réforme
on fait la distinction entre 10
trimestres cotisés avant les 20 ans 5
partir deux ans avant 10 partir 4 ans
avant bon c'est le dispositif de
carrière longue plutôt des personnes qui
plutôt
en fait jusqu'à présent l'immense
majorité des personnes qui sont dans les
carrières longues sont des personnes qui
ont quand même plutôt des métiers
pénibles quand vous arrêtez l'école très
tôt et que vous rentrez dans le dans le
marché du travail vous avez rarement un
travail qui est plutôt on va dire facile
en termes de conditions de travail alors
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui avec les
apprentis avec qui se sont plutôt
développés on commence à avoir quelques
personnes qui ont des métiers un peu
moins pénibles qu'avant mais ces
quelques personnes l'argument de dire
aujourd'hui toutes les carrières longues
ne se valent pas
c'est vrai mais enfin il y en a 90% qui
sont pénibles disent qu'ils ne sont pas
donc la proportion elle est quand même
très très faible
qu'elle soulevé Stéphane blackovski ça
vous a fait sursauter ou pas alors je
vous dire très franchement quand on a
reçu le texte quelques quelques heures
avant la déclaration de la première
ministre évidemment sous embargo on a
cru une coquille vraiment dire on n'y a
pas cru on a cru que c'était une erreur
de frappe dans le texte on avait tous
compris on était persuadés qu'on ne
pourrait pas aller au-delà de 43 années
de cotisations et honnêtement ces
personnes qui démarrent très jeunes un
elle démarre très jeune deux elles ont
des conditions de travail qui souvent
qui sont difficiles c'est seulement 19
20 ans c'est ça pas d'ailleurs
et 19 20 ans là vous aurez les 44
ça va dépendre chaque année si vous
décidez en début d'année ou en fin
d'année pour être plus ou moins touché
donc selon en plus la date de naissance
vous aurez plus ou moins de chance avoir
43 ou 44 ans mais ce qu'il faut préciser
c'est que quand vous travaillez très tôt
le corps est pas complètement fini à 16
ans 17 ans 18 ans enfin c'est il y a
encore des répercussions physiques qui
sont qui sont plus importantes donc ce
sont des personnes qui font plus
d'efforts qui ont des métiers plus
pénibles qui travaillent très tôt et
donc souvent les conséquences physiques
sur le corps arrive encore plus tôt et
on a un médecin il pourra sûrement le
confirmer et c'est personne là à la fin
se trouvent pénalisées en allant jusqu'à
44 ans honnêtement
mais certaines dans ces dispositifs là
honnêtement dire le mot c'est plus juste
avec ce raisonnement là on a quand même
beaucoup de mal à suivre oui évidemment
faudra peut-être un amendement non sur
ce point-là ah bah ça il y en aura pas
qu'un à mon avis il y en aura il y en
aura plusieurs oui mais vous pouvez
parce que je crois que les Françaises et
les Français ils ont envie qu'on
débattre qu'on démonte l'intégralité des
points et des et des et des micro point
parce que c'est des vies derrière moi ce
que je voudrais dire c'est qu'on peut
pas présenter ça comme juste que ceux
qui travaillent plutôt donc ceux qui se
mettent à cotiser pour payer les
retraites de leurs aînés et qui vont le
faire tout au long de leur vie plus
longtemps ils ont en fait une retraite
moins longue parce que ce sont les mêmes
en réalité qui ont une retraite moins
longue pourquoi ceux qui ont bénéficié
en dans le réel d'une retraite moins
longue parce qu'il meurt plutôt ce sont
ces catégories sociales là ce sont les
les classes populaires ce sont les
milieux modestes et quand on commence
effectivement à travailler à 17 à 18 ans
c'est pas forcément d'ailleurs qu'on a
un bac + 2 c'est qu'on commence à
travailler et qu'on peut pas poursuivre
ses études donc c'est évidemment c'est
comme un symbole de toute l'injustice de
cette réforme on parle beaucoup de
l'espérance de vie c'est vrai qu'elle
augmente il faut s'en féliciter qu'en
est-il de l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé parce qu'après tout c'est ça le
critère c'est le vrai suit un cercle
qu'on donne l'argument à dire
l'espérance de vie oui mais dans quel
état et il y a un autre indicateur qui
est l'espérance de vie sans incapacité
cette fameuse evsi qui est capitale
c'est à quel âge finalement je suis sans
incapacité dans ma vie quotidienne alors
c'est du déclaratif c'est une enquête
qui est faite dans tous les pays
européens d'ailleurs et on demande aux
gens à quel moment ils se sentent en
incapacité ou pas de faire les tâches de
la vie quotidienne et c'est un âge bien
moins élevé que
c'est 65 ans c'est à dire que on voit
que l'espérance de vie sans incapacité
en France elle est 65 ans elle a un peu
progressé ce qui veut dire que c'était
assez catastrophique avant quand même
parce que il y a quand même 20 points de
différence entre l'espérance de vie où
j'ai pas d'incapacité dans ma vie
quotidienne et le moment où je vais
mourir c'est en ces années finalement de
qualité de vie qui sont importantes
alors j'entends j'entends dire et moi je
suis pas un spécialiste du débat sur les
retraites moi ce que je vois mon point
de vue de médecin et les collègues
médecins du travail le voient encore
plus ce que je vois c'est la souffrance
au travail alors il y a la souffrance
physique qui est sous tendue parce que
vous dites quand vous dites quand on
commence jeune c'est des métiers
pénibles manuels physique etc mais il
n'y a pas que la souffrance physique
cette souffrance au travail elle est
réelle souffrance physique souffrance
psychique quand on regarde les chiffres
c'est un cadre sur 5 aussi et tous ces
critères de pénibilité ils sont
difficiles à apprécier même cette
espérance de vie sans incapacité c'est
une moyenne on fait pas la différence
par métier par exemple on n'a pas les
indicateurs dans le détail pour pouvoir
chiffrer quantifier ou apprécier
justement quels sont les professions les
plus pénibles
par filière alors on va parler de la
pénibilité dans un instant parce qu'on a
essayé de débats techniques mais
maintenant voilà on est au cœur du sujet
si j'ose dire on a bien compris que
l'opposition de gauche va batailler
ferme il y a déjà des amendements qui se
préparent voire des milliers
d'amendements il y a une personnalité à
droite qui a surprise ce matin sur ces
questions de justice écouter Xavier
Bertrand
réforme pour les gens qui vont bien hier
sur votre plateau si je ne me trompe pas
le ministre du travail était face à un
cadre qui lui a demandé qu'est-ce que ça
va changer pour moi et il a répondu quoi
le ministre rien voilà par contre pour
celui ou celle qui a commencé à
travailler très jeune mais avant 20 21
ans celui qui est donc moins formé celui
qui est moins payé lui il va devoir
faire 44 années de cotisation elle est
où la justice voilà je voulais vraiment
vous puissiez répondre on a entendu les
différentes positions Xavier Bertrand
les républicains qui sont plutôt
favorables à la réforme qu'est-ce que
vous lui répondez précisément clairement
pour tous ceux qui regardent ce soir je
lui je lui je lui réponds je lui demande
il nous demande où est la justice je lui
demande où est la cohérence la cohérence
par rapport au programme qu'il a porté
puisque il a porté dans son programme en
élection aux primaires présidentielles
le décalage de l'âge légal exactement ce
qu'on propose dans cette réforme sans
les mesures
sociales et de il vous interpelle sur
les 44 ans on a bien débattu hier déjà
des 64 ans le nouvel âge légal sur ce
point précis est-ce que c'est pas la
réforme des gens qui vont bien est-ce
qu'il y a pas des trous dans la raquette
est-ce que c'est on peut on peut changer
ce point est-ce que vous pourriez dire
je prendrai des amendements pour que en
gros personne ne travaille au delà de 43
années de cotisation il faut pas faire
passer la réforme comme une réforme
facile et et on préférerait ne pas avoir
cette réforme à faire il faut rappeler
un qui est nécessaire indispensable pour
pouvoir rester dans notre pacte social
et dans le maintien de ce système une
fois qu'on a dit ça pour répondre à
votre question il me semble important de
dire que cet effort il est demandé à
tous on aurait pu dire si on avait gardé
par exemple le départ de l'âge légal à
65 ans comme ça avait été discuté au
démarrage cette réforme aurait été plus
injuste puisque le fait d'augmenter la
cotisation la durée de cotisation
d'accélérer la réforme Turenne touche
les personnes qui sont plutôt qui on
fait plutôt des études donc pour moi
elle est beaucoup plus juste le fait
d'aller mis un plafond 64 ans
elle touche des gens qui n'auraient pas
été touchés si on avait décalé là je
légale que à 65 ans donc c'est c'est une
réforme qui est plus juste que tout le
monde travaille plus longtemps et on
annonce la carrière longue c'est ça la
réponse c'est un peu moins injuste
peut-être
quand même totalement injuste alors ça
c'était le premier point je propose
qu'on parle de la pénibilité puis on
dirait un mot des fonctionnaires des
enseignants dans un instant la
pénibilité là encore les syndicats
voulaient que les critères de pénibilité
soit rétablis ils ont été supprimés
avant de vous entendre on va partir sur
le terrain dans une entreprise de
déménageurs en Île-de-France reportage
et la nouvelle
bonjour madame
carton de livre de vaisselle table
canapé armoire machine à laver en une
matinée l'équipe déménagent ce pavillon
de 3 niveaux
il y a des jours c'est comme ça en
maison c'est proche ça pourrait être au
fond d'une course ça pourrait être
au 5e étage sans ascenseur c'est
exactement
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt bien
50 mètres cubes à 4 ce jour-là la pièce
maîtresse c'est ce piano c'est un bébé
c'est quand même de son kilos à soulever
et à extraire du sous-sol
des charges lourdes à porter toute la
journée d'eau courbée à monter et
descendre les escaliers un travail
pénible que ses déménageurs n'envisagent
pas de faire jusqu'à 64 ou 65 ans
jusqu'à 65 ans
à chaque fois on verra si on peut
[Musique]
à 33 ans dont la moitié dont le
déménagement Sylvian a même peur de
prendre sa retraite
c'est un boulot on est toujours actif le
jour où on s'arrête c'est jamais bon
pour l'organisme il n'aime pas ça moi
carrément j'ai peur de prendre ma
retraite maintenant même les anciens qui
ont arrêté ils étaient ils étaient en
meilleure forme quand tu bossais que
quand ils sont partis à la retraite et
ils ont pas beaucoup profité de leur
retraite en fait parce qu'ils sont morts
pas très longtemps après et ici pourtant
la société aménage les tâches pour les
plus âgées et elle organise les fins de
carrière je me suis arrangé avec mon
patron pour qu'ils puissent me laisser
un peu plus souvent au dépôt faire du
soudage de la mécanique à 59 ans et
après une déchirure musculaire au
travail Patrick a pu se reconvertir il
est devenu le mécano de l'équipe j'ai
une ceinture
rien à voir avec un exosquelette comme
certains disent c'est pas pour faire
joli c'est pour supporter la douleur du
dos et si nous on est pas en pénibilité
on marche sur la tête quoi je veux dire
car depuis 2017 le port de charge lourde
ne fait plus partie des six critères de
pénibilité qui permettent une retraite
anticipée
veulent savoir jusqu'à quel âge vont-ils
devoir travailler on est vraiment dans
le cas de figure emblématique des
charges lourdes d'un métier pénible
voire extrêmement pénible oui c'est
c'est toute la partie de la réforme qui
apporte des mesures vraiment
intéressantes il me semble sur la
pénibilité beaucoup qui ont d'ailleurs
été discutés et grâce à ce temps de
concertation qu'on a pu avoir avec les
représentations syndicales on a
plusieurs types de mesures on renforce
le compte pénibilité qui qui permet de
partir un peu plus tôt il y a des
mesures de création d'un d'un fond
d'investissement d'un fond dans la
branche d'assurance maladie à accident
de travail maladie professionnelle qui
va permettre que ces personnes là même
si elles ont commencé autour de 20 ans à
21 peut-être pas de dispositif carrière
longue pénibilité on part on a 70
personnes sur 10 va pouvoir partir avant
de façon avant les 64 c'est une c'est ce
qui est très important c'est que la
philosophie change c'est à dire jusque
là on va le maintenir il y a la
réparation c'est à dire vous avez eu un
métier difficile dans votre vie pénible
on vous répare c'est à dire que vous
partez un peu avant nous ce qu'on dit en
plus et travailler avec le
représentation syndicale réformiste
c'est de dire on va faire de la
prévention et on va dire on va donner
les moyens soit à vous former pendant
votre votre carrière pour pouvoir faire
une partie de votre vie un métier moins
pénible donc des droits à la formation
et puis un suivi médical très renforcé à
partir de la consultation obligatoire de
45 ans et un suivi médical personnalisé
alors je crois vraiment que c'est une un
point majeur de cette réforme parce que
c'est une révolution sur la prévention
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de questions
sur le suivi médical on va essayer d'y
voir un peu plus clair peut-être Sophie
Tellier polluant là-dessus la pénibilité
la première chose
c'est suivi médicaux par qui il y a plus
de médecins du travail ça fait tellement
d'années qu'on demande un plan pour
revaloriser la filière des médecins du
travail dans la médecine générale
c'est l'être morte aujourd'hui et la
précédente loi qui a été votée a mis en
plus grande difficulté la médecine du
travail et j'ajoute qu'avec la
disparition des CHSCT que vous avez
orchestré dans les ordonnances Macron en
2017 on constate que votre politique
elle elle nuit en fait à la prévention
des risques professionnels je prends les
griefs aujourd'hui on a une situation de
la prévention qui est détériorée c'est
juste le cas donc après on peut s'ériger
en chevalier blanc et inventer des
dispositifs de prévention en dirant en
disant qu'il y aura des médecins mais
quand il y en a pas il y en a pas et par
ailleurs aujourd'hui le compte
pénibilité il a été aussi démentibulé
par vos soins puisque il y a un certain
nombre de critères qui ont été retirés
et des seuils qui ne permettent qu'à
quelques personnes d'y accéder
personne par an voilà on aimerait
comprendre leur monde heureusement on
n'a pas un métier pénible aujourd'hui ça
fonctionne comment il y avait des
critères Laurent Berger de la CFDT
voulait qu'ils soient rétabli tout comme
vous à la CFTC ils n'ont pas été
rétablis mais il y a un compte
pénibilité ça marche comment
concrètement
peut-être pour que nos auditeurs
comprennent les spectateurs il faut il
faut bien comprendre qu'il y avait toute
une série de de critères de pénibilité
ce qu'on appelle dans un compte
pénibilité dans lequel le gouvernement
précédent en 2017 a retiré ce qu'on
appelle les critères ergonomiques les
critères ergonomiques sont les charges
lourdes les postures difficiles et donc
nous demandions alors le risque chimique
c'est un peu c'est un peu alors ça a été
retiré aussi mais c'est un peu à côté
parce que normalement on devrait pas
avoir de risques chimiques parce que
voilà mais pour ça que je mets un petit
peu de un petit peu de côté et ce qui
est très important de comprendre
aujourd'hui c'est que nous on demandait
que c'est que ces critères là soient
rétablis dans le compte pénibilité quand
vous avez un critère dans un compte
pénibilité vous avez on vous attribue
des points et on vous arrive à un
certain nombre de points vous partez
plutôt c'est simple vous avez à demander
à personne vous avez acquis suffisamment
de points pour partir plus tôt
aujourd'hui le le gouvernement alors là
fait un geste en redonnant la
possibilité d'intégrer ces critères
ergonomiques mais en fait c'est un demi
geste c'est à dire on les réintègre pas
dans le compte pénibilité c'est un peu
compliqué de à comprendre mais on les
met en fait on donne la possibilité à
ces critères
ergonomiques par une visite médicale de
fin de carrière avec un médecin du
travail qui pourrait reconnaître une
incapacité comme on a vu par exemple le
monsieur dans le dans le reportage
pourra bénéficier d'un départ anticipé
mais vous voyez que par rapport à ce
qu'on avait avant c'était automatique
par rapport à un nombre de points
aujourd'hui difficile à mettre après les
entreprises du texte
c'est le grand argument mais sur le
difficile à mettre en place moi je non
mais il y a des très très honnêtement je
l'entends sur certains certaines
filières le problème tient c'est que
pendant les trois mois de concertation
avec la première ministre elle a
toujours cité le même exemple qui suis
là est vrai et très compliqué qui est le
chauffeur livreur vous avez des
chauffeurs livreurs qui livrent des
colis de 20 kg ou de 30 kg des
chauffeurs livreurs qui vivent toute la
journée des colis de 2 kg c'est vrai ça
existe mais pendant trois mois j'ai eu
un exemple et toujours le même donc
j'aurais bien avoir un exemple c'est pas
forcément force force de loi par contre
oui là ce que je reconnais de positif
c'est qu'il y a un vrai effort fait sur
la prévention en tout cas une volonté de
faite sur la prévention parce que là on
pourrait se mettre d'accord c'est que le
plus important est pas forcément de
partir deux ans plus tôt enfin c'est
très important pour les gens mais le
plus important ça serait que des métiers
très pénibles on ne puisse pas les faire
pendant 40 ans parce que même si on part
à 59 si on part à 60 ans on a quand même
le dos brisé de la même manière voilà et
donc là on a ce congé de reconversion
qui devrait permettre de pouvoir espérer
se reconvertir encore il faut que ce
soit bien mis en place et est très
honnêtement on a beaucoup de choses à
faire on a tout à construire sur la sur
la prévention tout à construire parce
que on a des comptes très excédentaire
sur la TP mais s'ils sont très
accidentaires
et les accidents de travail mais s'ils
sont très excellentaires c'est qu'on est
très mauvais sur la prévention
du travail et les maladies
professionnelles sont progression
constante ce qui veut dire quoi ce qui
veut dire que il y a une espèce de
maltraitance au travail et au-delà
j'entends tous ces discours très
techniques etc mais ce que les gens
voient c'est que au travail que ça soit
psychiquement ou physiquement le monde
du travail n'est plus un monde
bienveillant et donc du coup c'est
extrêmement compliqué à faire comprendre
moi je le vois avec des patients qui
sont au bout du rouleau qui arrivent
dans les services d'urgence au bout du
rouleau physiquement le dos cassé
psychiquement cassé également et ces
gens-là je peux comprendre aisément quel
que soit le niveau d'ailleurs sociaux
professionnels disent je veux même pas
un mois de plus et toute cette bien
traitance au travail finalement elle est
complètement éludée l'autre chose qui
diffère beaucoup entre la théorie et la
pratique c'est
quand on regarde la médecine du travail
il nous dit la médecine du travail va
faire des visites etc mais effectivement
il y a plus de médecins du travail quel
est aussi la j'allais dire le champ de
compétences et la compétence des
médecins du travail on pourrait vraiment
se poser la question quel est le lien
avec l'indépendance
on se dit s'il y a une insulte médicale
qui donne un critère pénibilité un autre
médecin pourrait ne pas le donner pour y
avoir des disparités
il y a des services interprofessionnels
d'autres qui sont liés dans l'entreprise
moi j'aimerais qu'il y ait une vraie
réforme sur la médecine une vraie
réflexion une réforme sur la médecine du
travail pour que ça soit plus attractif
avec des gens qui sont à la fois
peut-être médecin traitant dans un
département et puis médecin du travail à
mi-temps et médecin du travail dans un
autre département un département d'à
côté comme ça il y aura un vrai suivi
une vraie connaissance
et de la médecine du travail
professionnel
c'est financée par les entreprises et
donc si vous voyez il y a un lien pareil
je voudrais dire on peut pas aborder la
question de la fête de la durée sur la
vie du temps de travail sans aborder la
question de l'évolution du travail on
nous dit on vit plus longtemps donc
c'est normal oui mais et ça c'est un
quelque chose qu'on a observé à travers
le monde il y a une intensification du
travail il y a dans les entreprises
aujourd'hui on demande plus aux salariés
les salariés sont plus contrôlés des
indicateurs par-ci des surveillances par
là des chronomètres des timings etc donc
aujourd'hui on a un travail qui
globalement même si on porte pas de
charge lourde est plus pénible donc ça
le gouvernement l'ignore ou le fait
semblant de l'ignorer et fait comme si
finalement tout allait toujours mieux et
formidablement et ce n'est pas le cas
minorités c'est une c'est une c'est une
évolution qui est internationale qu'il
faudrait prendre en compte il faut faire
attention à ce que à force de dire aussi
que tous les métiers sont pénibles de la
même manière il y a plus aucun métier
pénible donc il faut quand même très
bien sûr j'aimerais bien terminer mais
j'aimerais bien vous répondre
très importantes premièrement
l'espérance de vie n'augmente plus 2013
2021 l'espérance de vie n'est pas bougé
la baissée de 0,2 c'est ce que j'allais
dire elle baisse elle baisse
indépendante alors 2015 elle baisse mais
vous avez un tiers-maraison vous avez
peut-être deux ans c'est les données de
l'adresse vous avez entièrement 2013
depuis 2008 le chiffre est incontestable
2013 2021 - 0,1 sur 8 ans par contre
vous avez raison c'est dû à la covid
c'est dû à une canicule en 2014 donc il
a dit c'est dû un système il nous a dit
au ministère il y a des événements
exceptionnels qui ont fait que il me
semble je pense pas que ce soit ma
collègue qui est à ma droite qui est à
me contredire que on nous explique à
longueur de temps que dérèglement
climatiques etc on aura de plus en plus
de virus de plus en plus de
l'épidémie de température
pourrait devenir la règle et la deuxième
chose qui est très importante on a une
espérance de vie en bonne santé
aujourd'hui par filière et on voit que
nous avons des écarts entre filières qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à 15 voir 16 ans il
faut qu'un jour ou l'autre on se mette
autour de la table et qu'on puisse
ensemble dire que les personnes
en bonne santé ne peuvent pas
entendre Mara Goyer
silencieuse alors on a parlé des métiers
pénibles c'est pas forcément directement
celui d'enseignant mais j'imagine quand
même que le métier difficile très
difficile il faut imaginer que être
enseignant une journée d'enseignant ça
serait pour vous 7 heures de direct avec
30 invités pas très sages donc c'est un
métier complètement épuisant et nous on
vieillit dans ce voyage immobilier qui
est la classe et on est en face de nous
des élèves de 12 ans qui ont toujours 12
ans et qui changent au début ils ont
l'âge d'être nos petits frères petite
sœur puis de nos enfants puis de nos
petits-enfants et à 60 ans livré à 30
adolescents qui pourraient donc presque
être vos arrières petits enfants ça
devient vraiment très compliqué cette
réforme on en parle beaucoup dans les
salles de profs
il y a quelque chose de complètement
irresponsable dans le dans le système
éducatif c'est vous en parliez c'est la
médecine du travail je n'ai pas vu un
médecin depuis le début de ma carrière
je suis quand même au contact d'enfant
et là je vais essayer de ne pas être
corporatiste et de penser aux enfants
parce qu'après tout je pense que ça
permet de comprendre ce qu'on vit
personne ne surveille nos vaccinations
personne ne surveille notre état
psychique et c'est très très dur quand
vous allez mal et que vous êtes au
milieu d'adolescent c'est extrêmement
difficile et non seulement c'est
terrible pour les enseignants mais c'est
aussi puisque les enfants c'est plus
important que toutes ces sacrés peuvent
attention comment on peut laisser des
enseignants qui vont très mal ou qui
sont avec des maladies et tout ça alors
contact enfin voilà si les gens
accompagné par les enseignants qui le
soit par les enfants
miser sur la médecine du travail est-ce
que c'est le bon levier Stéphane je
crois vraiment
donc j'ai l'habitude de voir des gens
qui ont mal au dos ou aux articulations
pour parce que du fait de leur métier je
vois d'ailleurs des enseignants assez
régulièrement parce que la position qui
est souvent debout avec peu de de sport
enfin ou d'activité physique dans
l'exercice de l'enseignement peut
entraîner des douleurs et là où je
trouve que c'est vraiment important
c'est cette idée de travailler sur la
prévention sur la prévention de ces
troubles musculo-squelettiques les
douleurs un peu partout sur les douleurs
de dos et parce qu'on sait qu'on est
efficace quand on travaille en prêt la
prise en compte aussi dans la retraite
parce que c'est quand même l'objet du
jour bien sûr mais c'est ce que propose
cette réforme de la retraite d'un mot il
y a quelques éléments de justice ou
d'injustice encore on en a pas parlé les
régimes spéciaux alors c'est peut-être
pas forcément ce que vous souhaitiez
tous mais
si eux ils ont un ils sont
disponibilités
du travail mais moi je suis pour le
maintenir mais il y a beaucoup d'autres
métiers avec des risques aussi je
voudrais terminer ce débat sur la
question des femmes ça ça fait longtemps
déjà quand même que la question des
congés maternité on cotise pendant qu'on
est en congé maternité qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire pour plus de justice le
congé parental c'est ça va être présent
il y a plusieurs choses et moi je suis
ravie de pouvoir porter cette réforme et
notamment pour les mesures qui sont
faites pour les femmes vous savez qu'on
va augmenter la pension minimale à 1200
euros x 85 % du SMIC c'est 60% des cas
c'est des femmes ça c'est une mesure
pour les femmes on travaille sur les
carrières hachées c'est-à-dire les
personnes qui n'ont pas travaillé tout
au long de leur vie on va permettre pour
les gens qui ont pris des congés
parentaux d'avoir des endroits qui sont
ouverts dans ces congés parentaux pour
les proches aidants statistiquement
c'est aussi plus des femmes donc on a
des mesures particulièrement fortes pour
les femmes et une fierté de porter ça
dans cette région c'est une évidence
qu'on va continuer beaucoup à parler de
ses retraites ça ne fait que commencer
jour après jour semaine après semaine un
aspect positif bah merci merci Chabanier
de me permettre de conclure sur cette
note positive on vous déballéguer cette
question de la justice à travers
différents points de cette réforme merci
vous restez avec moi maragoillet dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties pris
de nos affranchis ce soir Isabelle
Lasserre va revenir sur le régime
iranien qui s'enfonce dans une violence
inouïe l'avocat Bertrand Perrier qui va
prendre la défense de Charlie Hebdo
après les publications de nouvelles
caricatures et puis Bourbon Express vous
la voyez elle est blonde elle est grande
elle est très talentueuse et là elles
amont un galva qui va nous parler du
retour d'Adrien catenin ça l'assemblée à
tout à l'heure les amis on va parler de
votre livre à présent finir prof il est
connoté ce vous nous direz pourquoi vous
l'avez choisi vous êtes enseignante
maragueil et je le disais dans un
collège aujourd'hui à Paris vous avez
été en Seine-Saint-Denis on en parle
dans un instant mais d'abord votre
portrait signé ce soir parti bonne
si on vous invite maragogaye c'est que
vous êtes l'une des porte-voix et des
portes plumes du malaise enseignant avec
25 ans d'enseignement en collège vous
êtes bien placé pour écrire sur le
tableau noir du malheur les mots de
l'école en la matière pour rester dans
Prévert l'inventaire est long crise de
vocation pour l'enseignement décrochage
du niveau de lecture et de calcul
constatés à l'entrée au collège
accroissement constant des écarts de
niveau climat délétères violence
profabou le tout provoque chez vous une
impression de gâchis auxquelles
cependant vous ne vous résignez pas Mara
Goyer vous êtes donc professeur
d'histoire-géographie depuis un quart de
siècle non plus d'une décennie passée en
zone d'éducation prioritaire de votre
expérience quotidienne vous tirez la
matière de vos essais à mi-chemin entre
la déclaration d'amour pour votre métier
et la désillusion la passion et la
colère est une catastrophe c'est
vraiment
c'est du jamais vu cette désaffection et
même plus personne n'a envie d'être
élève donc c'est une les élèves ont du
mal à aller à l'école ils sont dans un
état psychologique inquiétant donc on
est dans une situation très grave mais
je pense que ce n'est pas fichu je crois
qu'on peut donner envie d'être prof mais
pour donner envie d'être prof il faut
tenir un discours de vérité un discours
de vérité qui vous fait critiquer une
institution devenue trop gestionnaire à
vos yeux managérial pleine de
contraintes administratives et de normes
au détriment de ce qui est pour vous le
coeur de votre métier la classe une
classe dont vous faites un champ
d'expérimentation et d'improvisation
permanente enseignante atypique vous
prenez une pédagogie sur mesure qui
partent des élèves et non de l'Académie
c'est ainsi que Rihanna et des rappeurs
français s'invite dans vos cours dans
votre dernier livre vous racontez votre
expérience des récentes crises subies
par l'école l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
et les attaques contre la laïcité mais
aussi les divers le confinement et les
conséquences des fermetures de classe
sur ce point vous tirez un bilan à
l'armiste le fléau du décrochage s'est
accentué davantage d'élèves sont
concernés ils ne font même plus mine de
participer ni de s'impliquer ce sont des
élèves mutiques parfois prostrés qu'on
ne parvient plus à aller chercher alors
maragogaye alors qu'une nouvelle réforme
du collège se profile que le ministre de
l'Éducation a déjà annoncé une heure de
lecture supplémentaire en 6ème assurée
par des professeurs des écoles que faire
pour redresser la barre quel serait
votre principal décision si vous étiez
ministre
elle est très bonne cette question
je pense que changer la formation des
enseignants les les déjà pour les faire
revenir il faudrait rendre le métier
plus vrai et plus attractif notamment
dans cette difficulté je pense qu'il
faut cesser
ce discours lyrique sur le métier qui a
du sens on dit aux gens que ça va être
un métier extraordinaire ils vont
s'accomplir ils arrivent à 24 ans dans
un collège très difficile il s'en
prennent parfois plein la figure
ils connaissent aussi des moments
incroyables et ce décalage entre le
lyrisme et ce que vivent les enseignants
n'est plus tenable donc voilà ça c'est
pas une mesure mais ça serait déjà un
changement de ton et un changement de
perspective il faut partir de la classe
on est en classe avec les élèves on a
les élèves qu'on a il y a toujours ce
spectre des élèves qu'on devrait avoir
qui devrait être comme ça ben non ils
sont comme ça les élèves et comment on
fait pour faire notre métier
sérieusement et librement comment on
fait pour finir prof déjà pourquoi ce
titre il est il est connoté évidemment
ce titre finir prof aujourd'hui dans
l'imaginaire collectif c'est avoir raté
sa vie exactement si vous regardez pour
démontrer le contraire que vous avez
écrit j'aimais bien c'était un peu
provocateur parce que j'ai fini prof à
24 ans et là je vais avoir 50 ans et je
continue de finir prof parce que je suis
encore prof
j'aimais bien le côté brutal voilà et
polysémique de finir prof j'avais envie
que le titre
interpelle sur la manière dont on
considère ce métier d'ailleurs très
tenace cette perception parce que vous
racontez que l'une de vos connaissances
vous a dit c'est bien de se mentir oui
parce que j'étais contente et et encore
aujourd'hui on va dire dans mon livre en
effet je suis j'explique que je suis
très heureuse d'être prof et ça veut pas
dire que c'est facile je suis pas
complètement éthérée et déconnecté ni
naïve c'est un métier difficile je
l'aime pour sa difficulté même s'il est
aujourd'hui
je suis dans des conditions beaucoup
plus facile que lorsque j'ai commencé
mais
vous êtes aujourd'hui à Paris dans le
7ème arrondissement mais mais il
n'empêche que l'enseignement n'est nulle
part facile c'est comment on fait alors
pour se renouveler les programmes ne
changent pas les profs à la main
il faut se réinventer sinon c'est quoi
c'est l'ennui c'est ah oui c'est morbide
le cycle de ces sisif quoi on recommence
on recommence et puis ils ont toujours
11 ans mais ils sont différents et nous
on est vieux enfin là on parlait des
retraites c'est quand même très
compliqué il faut être ferme et souple
dans la classe qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ça je crois surtout qu'il faut
sortir justement je dis c'est ça pour
sortir des débats stériles sur
l'autorité la démagogie c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe avec les élèves
quand on est rigide totalement
intransigeant mais en fin de compte on
fiche tout le monde et on obtient rien
d'intéressant être ferme c'est quand
même savoir qu'on est là pour bosser
pour travailler faire le programme être
sérieux être exigeant enfin voilà être
normal on peut ouvrir des questions dans
la classe mais pas toutes vous dites on
ne conteste pas une consigne en maths ou
un roman à lire en revanche on peut
s'arrêter quand nécessaire voilà c'est
ça c'est ça être souple c'est tout d'un
coup avoir même une conception du temps
de dans le cours et dans la semaine qui
sont un peu souple savoir s'arrêter
savoir accélérer mais ça veut dire quoi
parce que vous racontez votre classe
elle ressemble à un homme d'ibus qui
s'arrête souvent sur quel sujet comme je
suis professeur d'histoire-géo
évidemment on s'arrête souvent parce que
on s'arrête je sais pas sur une remarque
à propos de l'homosexualité des
remarques sur l'identité sur les élèves
quand on les laisse un peu respirer et
s'exprimer ils ont des remarques
totalement imprévisibles souvent de bon
sens parfois anachronique ou et
il faut s'arrêter il faut discuter
d'ailleurs les élèves eux-mêmes le
disent on a besoin de discuter ils ont
besoin je sais pas quand vous parlez par
exemple de l'esclavage ou de dans
l'actualité quand on parle du
déboulonnage des statues ils ont besoin
d'en discuter on peut pas enseigner
comme si les élèves étaient coupés des
débats qui entourent les questions
présentes sur les réseaux
qu'il faut les avoir aussi dans la
classe on peut pas fermer la porte à ses
états tout en menant le débat il s'agit
pas non plus de de laisser dire
n'importe quoi mais ils ont besoin de
parler et on est là pour ça donc il faut
s'arrêter et ne faut aussi terminer le
programme mais il faut faire les deux
quoi donc c'est un peu la suite de votre
grande saga sur le collège vous avez
beaucoup écrit mais là c'est un essai
extrêmement personnel on plonge dans
votre classe c'est incarner il y a
énormément d'anecdotes vous racontez par
exemple qu'un élève vous dit vous à un
moment donné vous les chrétiens comme
s'il y avait deux mondes en gros le
vôtre et le sien qu'est-ce qu'on fait
dans ces moments-là déjà pour moi c'est
facile parce que je ne suis pas
chrétienne donc c'est j'ai des billes
pour répondre non mais ça c'est un vrai
travail plus général sur le vous et nous
ça c'est quelque chose qui est
persistant et d'ailleurs
c'est incroyable quand on demande aux
élèves quelle est leur nationalité
ils sont très nombreux à ne pas savoir
ils savent pas
je dis mais je sais pas tu as un
passeport ou une carte d'identité c'est
lequel pays tout ça dit ah ouais j'ai
une cadité carte d'identité française
dans ce cas là tu es française et c'est
c'est incroyable il y a tout à fait il
faut discuter affronter les questions
de manière ferme et souple alors je
voudrais qu'on parle du confinement
parce que là on découvre que pour vous
alors on est complètement rebours de
tous les discours des profs qu'on a pu
entendre dans les médias c'est une forme
de libération
évidemment il y a des contraintes et
c'est terrible mais en même temps les
cours à distance il faut capter les
élèves parce qu'ils peuvent regarder
ailleurs et donc on se renouvelle là
encore d'abord oui pour beaucoup
d'enseignants c'était très difficile
et pour les élèves aussi énormément
d'élèves ont décroché ça a été
dramatique quand même le bilan est
plutôt négatif mais
souvent ce qu'il y a de positif il y a
des choses formidables c'est à dire que
il y avait l'écran de la classe
virtuelle je voyais mes élèves qui me
voyaient qui se voyaient les uns les
autres je les voyais apprendre il se
voyaient les uns les autres à prendre il
me voyait essayer de faire court il y a
une sorte de révélation et de vérité de
la classe qui est apparue et puis aussi
dans ce contexte très personnel où
chacun était chez soi avec les parents
sur les côtés planqués ils entendaient
parfois rigoler les parents il y avait
quelque chose de d'extrêmement bien on
était reclu mais d'ouvert et puis le
lien s'est développé de manière
incroyable et j'ai même peut-être un peu
moins aussi peut-être par une
institution qui peut peser sur moi
surtout oui par l'institution et la
volonté de d'être toujours dans les
clous là il fallait tout faire pour les
garder et je me suis guéri de ma peur de
la pédagogie en faisant des petits jeux
des petites activités avec eux pendant
les vacances scolaires ou tout d'un coup
j'étais plus mono que prof et j'en ai
gardé quelque chose ça de un moment s'il
n'arrive plus à travailler on travaille
pas enfin on fait quelque chose qui peut
être intéressant et mais c'est dingue
quand même le nombre de choses qu'on
s'interdit de faire vous avez vu pendant
la campagne présidentielle les critiques
justement sur ce qu'on peut appeler le
pédagogie mais il faut amuser les élèves
les les attirer leur curiosité et c'est
dans des et ça c'est comment vous
réagissez parce qu'il y a eu même des
candidats à la présidentielle
c'est des faux débats il faut être à la
fois
ce débat entre pédagogue et républicain
c'est il est dans le formol il existe
pas vraiment sur place ce qu'il faut
c'est faire des choses qui est du sens
il faut si on croit à l'intérêt de ce
qu'on transmet il faut le transmettre de
manière intéressante
avec tous les moyens possibles qu'on
peut imaginer de l'imagination de la
variété pour le transmettre donc
heureusement qu'on fait qu'on a de la
pédagogie la pédagogie c'est pas quelque
chose de de fixe de réducteur et tout ça
et heureusement aussi qu'on a des
exigences et que on est attaché à notre
matière et qu'on veut transmettre des
choses extrêmement ardues et raffiné et
voilà donc c'est ça s'appelle finir prof
et il y a un sous-titre important
peut-on se réconcilier avec le collège
au fond malgré les difficultés et vous
n'êtes pas tendre avec les institutions
c'est un livre optimiste c'est un livre
extrêmement personnel que je conseille à
noter les spectateurs sécher Flammarion
vous restez avec moi maragoillet
les éditeurs n'aiment pas qu'on se
trouve Robert Laffont c'est corrigé
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris vous
allez voir ils vont vous faire réagir on
les accueille tout de suite
installez-vous les affranchies nouveau
décor il faut prendre un peu ses marques
deux affranchis ce soir toute verte
vêtue Isabelle lacer du Figaro pour
l'international vous allez revenir ce
soir sur la répression toujours plus
forte toujours plus féroce du régime des
Mola et puis l'avocat Bertrand Paris
qu'on est ravi de retrouver dans ce beau
décor vous allez prendre la défense
mettre ce soir de Charlie Hebdo après sa
récente une qui caricature justement ces
mots-là mais on commence comme promis
avec Bourbon Express histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée c'est vous qui nous la
racontez elles amont d'un GABA c'est
l'histoire d'un retour très controversé
oui ce soir je vous raconte l'histoire
d'un retour annoncé reporté finalement
un retour surprise un retour très
contesté ce matin les députés membres de
la commission des affaires étrangères
les étudient un rapport sur le corps
diplomatique alors c'est très
intéressant mais pas de quoi non plus
faire la une de tous les journaux sauf
que très vite il y a un député dans la
salle de commission qui va très très
vite attirer l'attention ce député c'est
il est entouré en rouge à l'image c'est
Adrien katnens député condamné pour
violence conjugale il est suspendu de
son groupe des insoumis jusqu'au mois
d'avril il siège donc à présent
aujourd'hui parmi les non inscrits et il
était donc à cette réunion evidemment à
ce moment-là une fois que l'information
a chuté tous les journalistes se sont
pressés devant cette commission qui
n'est pas ici dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale elle est dans une
rue juste derrière Adrien catenin son
l'attendait on voyait présent bien en
commission on se demandait s'il allait
sortir par une porte dérobée ou s'il
allait bien passer devant la presse et
bien un peu après 13h il a décidé de
venir de passer et de répondre au
journaliste alors
la décision prise par mon groupe
politique voilà merci à tous et bonne
journée pour que les personnes condamné
pour violon
voilà une petite phrase et puis ensuite
et bien 300 mètres au patchage pour
rejoindre son bureau à l'Assemblée
nationale entouré vous le voyez d'une
meute de journaliste on lui a demandé
s'il comprenait que son retour puis
choquer pas de réponse il s'est contenté
de dire ce qu'il nous avait dit face
caméra qu'il ne faisait qu'exercer son
travail de parlementaire là regardez il
va il rentre dans son bureau à
l'Assemblée nationale l'entrée donc
remarqué c'est impressionnant la forêt
de caméra qui l'entoure les réactions
nombreuses on l'imagine oui évidemment
alors une des premières à dégainer c'est
Aurore berger Aurore berger c'est la
présidente du groupe Renaissance Adrien
ce n'est toujours pas encore sorti de la
commission mais elle improvise une
conférence de presse juste devant le
bâtiment il est accompagné de Sacha
Ollier c'est le président de la
commission des lois il n'est pas
question de laisser passer ce retour
sous silence écouter
on avait peut-être l'espoir un peu naïf
qu'ils comprennent de lui-même que sa
place n'était plus évidemment au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui au
lendemain même d'ailleurs de la
présentation du projet de loi de réforme
des retraites par le gouvernement il
juge sa présence
utile il juge sa présence évidente il
revient comme si de rien n'était au sein
de la commission des affaires étrangères
il est une évidence pour nous encore une
fois que sa place ne peut plus être à
l'Assemblée nationale ne doit plus
l'être et la réponse politique c'est ça
cette proposition de loi distribue à
tous les journalistes présents pour
créer une peine d'innell éligibilité en
cas de condamnation pour violence
conjugale alors au sein de la nuque
évidemment ça réagit aussi Sabrina
sebahi elle est porte-parole des
écologistes elle était présente en salle
de commission lui a demandé bien comment
elle avait réagi quand elle a vu Adrien
quel a été votre réaction quand vous
avez vu Adrien katmain c'est arrivé dans
la salle en réalité j'ai été très très
étonnée parce que enfin on n'avait pas
du tout eu vent d'un éventuel retour au
contraire un corps hier certains de ses
collègues enfin de ses collègues de la
France insoumise disait qu'il valait
mieux qu'il ne revienne pas
immédiatement et là c'était très
étonnant de le voir revenir ce matin
même embarras un côté socialiste et
communiste qui visiblement n'était pas
non plus au courant il renvoie la
responsabilité au député plus largement
à son groupe même s'il précise bien que
chez eux ça ne se passerait pas comme ça
et soumis alors ils étaient où les
insoumis ah bah les insoumises étaient
pas bavards pas bavard du tout
aujourd'hui on a essayé essayé allez on
a obtenu deux phrases similiées
effectivement c'est bref ce retour il
gêne il gêne la gauche qui elle aurait
voulu parler retraites toute la journée
et pas du cas d'Adrien
ce retour surtout enfin surtout ce que
je trouve c'est que c'est complètement
illisible je me mets à la place des
lèvres qui regardent ça il ne
comprennent pas le traitement des
violences conjugales elles sont liées
nationales vraiment ils comprennent pas
si c'est plus grave d'être violent quand
on est à droite que quand on est à
gauche moi franchement je me mets à la
place d'un élève c'est incohérent et je
trouve ça toujours on parle
d'exemplarité et je trouve que cette
image donnée
[Musique]
incohérente du traitement des violences
conjugales et vraiment désastreux il
faudrait qu'une règle commune à tous les
groupes politiques c'est eux qui
consombe pas dans des situations comme
ça en tout cas après moi je
suis pas là pour juger mais c'est
important de savoir votre réaction
d'enseignant de professeur allez on
passe à l'international Isabelle vous
vouliez revenir après plus de 100 jours
déjà de révolte en Iran sur le régime
des mots là le régime féroce des Molas
qui pousse un grand suprême
supplémentaire dans la répression oui
papa je suis condamné à mort ne le dis
pas à maman ce sont les derniers mots
absolument terribles de mohammam Mehdi
Karami il avait 27 ans c'était un
champion de karaté et il a été pendu
samedi et ces dernières paroles
aujourd'hui sont reprises de manière
virale par les manifestants qui les
peignent sur les murs son seul tort il
avait participé à une manifestation au
cours de laquelle un paramilitaire avait
été tué la répression qui s'abat sur les
jeunes Iraniens et tout simplement
effroyable torture viol exécution au
moins 18000 personnes ont été arrêtées
dont des journalistes des sportifs des
acteurs et la fille de l'ancien
président Raph sanggiani 14 ont été
condamnés à mort accusés de délice
surréalistes comme inimitié envers Dieu
ou encore cor sur terre 4 ont déjà été
exécutés les morts se comptent par
centaines au moins 500 mais c'est
difficile à savoir parce que les corps
souvent ne sont pas rendus à la famille
les Iraniens sont habitués à la
répression de la dictature islamiste
mais celle-ci est particulièrement
sanglante et elle est aussi très
hermétique totalement hermétique aux
condamnations unanime des Européens et
les manifestants eux sont toujours là
ils ne faiblissent pas mais non la
répression au contraire semble gonfler
au début c'était les femmes qui
manifestaient dans la rue peut-être nu
pour protester contre après la mort de
Macha Amini cette jeune iranienne
arrêtée et battue parce qu'elle avait
mal mis son voile depuis toute la
jeunesse est descendue dans la rue pour
réclamer davantage de liberté et la
chute du régime et les malgré
l'intensification de la répression elle
a gagné aujourd'hui l'ensemble du pays
alors quand on voit aujourd'hui ces
femmes se déplacer tête nues sans voile
dans le métro ou dans la rue on se dit
que la révolution est en marche et que
les choses ne pourront jamais revenir en
arrière
davantage que la l'illusoir libération
des femmes afghanes qui après la chute
des talibans avaient pu pendant quelques
mois ou quelques années pour certaines
se débarrasser de la burqa la Révolution
la contestation iranienne fait penser à
la révolution tunisienne de 2010 qui
avait été déclenché par le suicide par
immolation du vendeur ambulant
souvenez-vous boisizi elle avait conduit
à la chute de Ben Ali et au
déclenchement des printemps arabe cette
fois vous pensez que le régime iranien
peut chuter on en est pas encore là le
régime est fragilisé la violence de la
répression le prouve plusieurs
dignitaires religieux ont critiqué la
gestion de la contestation par le
pouvoir mais pour qu'une rébellion se
transforme en révolution et chasse tout
sur son passage il faut qu'elle soit
rejointe par une partie au moins des
forces de sécurité or nul fissure
aujourd'hui dans le principal pilier du
régime les Gardiens de la Révolution pas
de craquement non plus dans l'armée
régulière quand on clergé site pour
l'instant il tient bon derrière le guide
suprême
qui semble décider à mater la rébellion
à tout prix je vais vous faire réagir
maraboyer dans un instant mais la
chronique de Bertrand elle est liée à
celle d'Isabelle excellente Isabelle
Lasserre des pages internationales du
Figaro maître Perrier ce soir vous
prenez la défense de Charlie Hebdo qui
publie encore hier un dessin qui n'a pas
plu au régime qui critique les mots là
on va aller voir c'est une
ces dessins oui ils sont frappants c'est
dans le cas d'un concours de dessin et
de caricatures qui a été lancé par
Charlie pour précisément soutenir le
mouvement social en cours en Iran et
donc il y a cette marque de fabrique de
Charlie à ses dessins outrancier
scabreux et qui ont provoqué des
réactions des officiels iraniens le
ministère des Affaires étrangères a fait
un tweet en disant que la France avait
opté pour la mauvaise voie je cite
l'Institut français de Teyran a été
fermé des drapeaux français ont été
brûlés et donc il y a un sentiment anti
français très fort attisé par le régime
iranien à la suite de ces caricatures on
est 8 ans après l'assassinat des
dessinateurs de Charlie exactement oui
et donc il faut unlassablement rappeler
évidemment non seulement que Charlie
Hebdo n'est pas un journal officiel qui
n'engage pas la France mais que au-delà
en France la liberté de la presse
comporte la faculté de critiquer voire
de caricaturer les religions en fait
dans la caricature il y a un pacte
implicite entre celui qui dessine et
celui qui de garde ce pacte c'est que la
caricature n'est pas le réel la
caricature c'est une outrance c'est
quelque chose qui est destiné à faire
rire à choquer à engager le débat mais
non pas à représenter le réel d'ailleurs
le mot caricature vient d'un mot qui
veut dire charge donc c'est bien forcé
le trait qui est la caractéristique de
la caricature et en cela elle est
indissociable de l'esprit critique avec
lequel on doit la regarder et ça pose
encore et toujours la question du droit
au blasphème qui est un droit il faut le
redire en notre pays le redire le redire
après Charlie aussi après Samuel Paty
oui le blasphème est un droit en France
il y a cette distinction un peu subtile
en effet on ne peut pas appeler à la
haine des fidèles d'une religion mais on
peut critiquer violemment éventuellement
une religion elle-même comme dans toute
idéologie on a le droit pour reprendre
le titre de l'ouvrage de mon confrère
Richard Malka le droit d'emmerder Dieu
et et ce qui disent on doit être Charlie
même s'ils exagèrent à cela je veux dire
en fait on doit être Charlie parce
qu'ils exagèrent c'est ce droit à
l'outrans dans le propos qui doit être
préservé et on ne peut pas se prétexte
de tolérance de pas de vagues même de
peur on ne peut pas renoncer à cette
universalisme qui fait notre
civilisation parce que les petits
renoncements d'aujourd'hui font les
grandes censures de demain droit à
caricatures oui même si ça peut avoir
des conséquences sur notamment la
question des otages français en Iran
c'est d'ailleurs votre collègue au
Figaro Georges ben Renaud qui le
soulignait oui c'est vrai il a raison
mais l'abdication de nos libertés aurait
aussi et un prix et rappelons que vous
l'avez dit pendant que les molas
s'offusquent de simples dessins et bien
par ailleurs ils n'ont pas d'hésitation
à exécuter au petit jour des jeunes gens
condamné à l'issue de procès expéditifs
et dont le Thor a été simplement de
manifester contre le régime je veux donc
redire cette phrase de Voltaire il est
honteux que les fanatiques et du zèle et
que les sages n'en est pas
le mot de la fin j'imagine que vous
l'avez eu ce débat avec vos élèves
notamment après
Charlie Charlie Hebdo aussi il est sans
cesse à refaire ce débat il est
considérable
les élèves ont beau être convaincu que
l'attentat de Charlie Hebdo
est horrible ils disent oui mais oui
mais quand même oui mais c'était pas une
raison mais et vraiment il y a une chose
contre lequel laquelle il faut lutter
c'est le oui mais on ne tue pas et
parfois justement
dans rapidement à la suite des attentats
on s'est trop perdu dans des
considérations sur qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire et tout ça c'est
pas avec les élèves il faut dire on ne
tue pas il n'y a aucune raison merci
beaucoup Mara gay de nous avoir
accompagné en direct dans cette émission
l'idée finir prof aux éditions Robert
Laffont merci beaucoup pour vos cartes
blanches vous partez pris ce soir à
demain Elsa et à demain à vous j'espère
fidèle au rendez-vous très belle soirée
sur
[Musique]